one of the biggest challenges is to
understand coverage because that's what
we're aiming for we're aiming for a rich
corpus of data that has has as much
coverage of the marathon as is possible
now what coverage actually means kind of
depends on what you ultimately might
want to do with this video now again if
you look at the kind of the professional
kind of broadcast they tend to focus on
the frontrunners kind of the
professional athlete who's going to win
and then a few broad shots of s the fun
runners may be picking out kind of
people of interest always the guy
running in the chicken suit for charity
for example but what we wanted to do was
try and see if we could build rich
enough video that we could tell a story
of any individual runner taking part in
the marathon so can we get kind of
multiple shots of any given runner so
for example not just the guy in the
chicken suit in kind of one particular
location but can we tell his story as
they start at the start line from
various kind of vantage points around
the course and then film them again as
they cross the finish line and so and
for any given kind of fun runner or
charity runner can we begin to do that
well there's some real notable ones that
you got right wow that's brilliant I
think we weren't we were we were
surprised just by kind of an arbitrary
couple that we took that we took out
that about how recognizable a person was
when you know that runner 123 is wearing
an orange top and you've seen him in
four videos then it's remarkably easy to
then find that a person in given a
minute of minute of video so what we're
also now and trying to do with this
video set is also adds additional
interesting information that allow us to
tell different stories to aren't just
kind of threw by runner number
so what more we did is we had an
exercise where we basically presented
all of our video fragments to a bunch of
people and we fed them Peter in as a
reward for doing this and but we had
asked them to watch the video in kind of
one minute fragments and tagged anything
that they thought was interesting that
somebody else might like to watch and so
there's all sorts of crazy stuff that
happens at the marathon list as there's
hundreds of people dressed as Robin Hood
there's people wearing costumes there's
people running for charity there's bands
playing by the side of the road all this
stuff might get captured but in our in
our corpus video that again add
interesting color to telling stories of
the marathon so another story we might
tell is of all of the robin hoods in the
marathon as opposed to just like an
individual runner so we got people to
tag the video and we got them to tag it
by kind of quality so is there a finger
in front of the lens is it pointing at
the Sun yeah is it pointing at the Sun
is it a stable shop is it by the side of
a road is in parkland are people
clapping and cheering and then also
thinking about the content so other
people in fancy dress are the runners
running or are they walking are there
any Robin Hood's you know add any any
kind of a ditional information and then
again we can kind of add this add this
information to kind of enrich our
stories so for example we have footage
of a rather running a race dressed as
the Cookie Monster for charity and we
have tags of him by his run a number but
now we also have multiple tags of him as
Cookie Monster so again we can apply the
same approach and pull out eight videos
of the Cookie Monster a various points
around the race the next step for this
is to basically build an online
repository so the idea is that people
collect these videos and they're
immediately made available online so
people can look for people they know and
we can also automatically pull out
videos that we know that they're in but
also videos that they might be in can
get the person who's perhaps interested
in seeing the Cookie Monster to help us
further enrich the data set so again
this is this human computation task
looking for cookie monster automatically
in a video is probably difficult but
people are really good at it and so
hopefully they can allow us to kind of
pin down more instances like you wanted
us you're basically saying that rather
than waiting through if you're looking
for the Cookie Monster maybe while the
cookie monster in you again you're nice
you don't have to wade through the 12
hours of footage because we can work out
or give you a good guesser yeah yeah you
probably get obesity I don't even have
to look through an hour yeah yeah
exactly exactly and so we can give you
clip so you're definitely in and those
that you might be in and you may be kind
of tagging people you recognize and
further points of interest all helps to
kind of making the corpus of data much
more interesting and therefore much more
interesting for future people to look at
so we hope so until we think this is
this is a process where throughout we
have people kind of capturing and
tagging data and adding points of
interest and that only serves to enrich
the data and make it more navigable and
allow us to tell stories better with so
do you see this is an archiving thing or
a or a thing for the people who in the
race or I think for research or I think
all of those F so it's definitely
interesting well we hope it's
interesting for people who were in the
race to be able to kind of pull out
footage for themselves I think it's
interesting for people who perhaps we're
spectators at the marathon or perhaps
couldn't be there so for example if you
know somebody you knew was running in
the marathon but you couldn't physically
be there then you can perhaps still
relive some of that experience or dog
can re-engage with it in some way I
think there's an archival tool it's
quite it's quite useful so we have a we
have an interesting large well the
collection of videos that might be
useful for somebody at some point and I
think there's an argument for actually
applying some of these techniques to
things other than a marathon so we've
chosen the marathon because it's perhaps
the most obvious example but you might
think you could do this with anything
that goes along a linear geographically
kind of rude so you know the Tour de
France it's kind of rally rally racing
kind of any any kind of sporting event
but i think i'm also interested in
thinking how it could be applicable to
music events gigs and festivals citizen
journalism kind of riots and kind of
reconstructing riots and what happened
has been an interesting thing recently
be illegal too yeah yeah exactly and so
there are a lot that raises a lot of
kind of interesting connotations as to
yeah what it means when the crowd is
suddenly available is suddenly able to
kind of collect and make sense of a
large portion of information kind of by
themselves without having to rely on
kind of the big organizations to do it
for them so yeah the interesting things
for research or understanding the
ability of a crowd to collect this data
what are the issues we've already seen
some so issues have kind of camera work
can we train people automatically to
hold their camera steady how do we kind
of direct people around the course and
we kind of orchestrating a crowd to the
hole because yeah I mean obviously this
is me with my song on and but
potentially the people could be pointing
the wrong direction making a frame wrong
the obvious things you have said about
shaky cameras and things but yeah you
know yeah and so we might we might think
about how we so research wise we might
think about how we improve our corpus an
improvement doesn't just mean getting
more footage it means getting better
footage so in the same way I guess a
modern stills camera will detect when
you're smiling and then automatically
take the picture we might have things
that instruct you in how to take better
better footage so for example maybe yeah
maybe when you start to power up it kind
of tells you what kind of
shots it needs or wants to help the best
contribute to the Kosmos if you've got
five people in that in the very near
facility you can then ask those five
people yet yeah or maybe move to
different places or maybe it's kind of I
think it's give and take we might say if
we know that you're here to watch your
uncle we might say if you go to this bit
of the course you'll be able to see your
uncle because he's going to turn up in
about ten minutes because he's been
tagged ten minutes ago and also you're
helping to fill a hole in our video
coverage she says some peoples are the
industry most days were you telling me
yeah yeah oh but one of the real one of
the big challenges is to kind of
sensitively balance people's experience
of being a spectator because when
they're not there to be camera operators
they're there to spectate have a good
time so it's about sensitively balancing
that while also being able to collect
some interesting footage from them I'm
gonna be going to XYZ event next I mean
how can I get involved this one can I
use your technology oh yes absolutely
the challenge with the biggest challenge
with crowdsourcing so essentially this
is what we're doing is crowdsourcing the
biggest challenge with crowdsourcing is
assembling a crowd you need people to do
this it doesn't work if you don't have
enough people so the first time we did
this we we explicitly recruited people
so we thought he bribed them to take
part together our initial corpus but now
what we want to do is kind of make this
more available and get people to use it
kind of on mass essentially and to also
begin to understand kind of how people
use it naturally so when they're not
explicitly asked to ask for it so what
we're planning on doing is is trying to
be a bit more organized making our app
available kind of through the app store
that kind of thing we're hoping to
develop it for for multiple platforms
and then to advertise when weird is
deploying add certain races though to
have a concerted effort to kind of
for example at the next marathon
wherever is to have a concerted effort
to make it available and advertising and
get people using it because the more
people who use it that the better our
collection of footage is okay so even if
only one person uses it you know we've
still got one point of view of the
marathon the more people you use it the
more points of view we can get so that
that's that's my aim moving forward is
to definitely make it available
encourage people to download it and use
it for upcoming events and marathons and
then see what we get from it because
yeah I can see the use of all sorts
things from running skiing downhill
mountain by racing through to Bob site
you know you name it it could be
anything that takes place ad reps but
even if I suppose a team of them good
yeah you know if you're watching a rugby
match in your on one side of pitching 20
people on different parts that page yeah
yeah yeahs sport professional sport and
gets really difficult because of
broadcasting rights lawyers tend to get
involved so we like doing we like doing
kind of things that a bit a bit a bit
less commercial a bit more kind of
interesting for the local community for
example so so perhaps school school
football market or school yeah yeah yeah
but even I suppose that comes to if my
American if there's a band playing your
music oh yeah yeah personally I'm really
interested in understanding how this
might work for festivals music festivals
so people milling around kind of filming
stuff that I think is interesting what's
what's the kind of the navigable online
version of Glastonbury that you can
visit because you can get a ticket
because that sold out too quickly for
example but that opens a whole can of
worms about kind of yeah broadcasting
filming bootlegging that that kind of
thing and but I think this I think
fundamentally the idea of crowdsourcing
footage in general whether or not its
tags
and kind of visualized in exactly the
way we've done it it's certainly a
growing ability that we all have there's
a bunch of tools popping up now where
you record a bunch of people go to a gig
and they record footage of the band
playing and it automatically uses the
the soundtrack to sync up those clips to
protect a provider to provider a single
video there's a bunch of examples of
this so so like father the Beastie Boys
organized a kind of your crowd a crowd
videoed video as did some bunch of
Radiohead fans so it's interesting that
a bunch of people are kind of like
self-organizing in order to collect this
stuff I think what makes the marathon
stuff interesting is there's no common
frame of reference for stitching this
stuff together and understanding it
purely got the clock yeah you view
purely got the clock so there's no
there's no global soundtrack that we can
use to kind of make sense for these of
all these videos so they're they're
they're at the it's like I suppose if
you're ten thousand runners that's like
10,000 songs or 10 years and stories
yeah yeah exactly so I think so i think
it's interesting to think about a
spectrum of these events whereas and a
gig there's one point of focus and
there's there's basically one story to
be told whereas at a marathon there's
ten thousand stories to be told and so
that's that's where it becomes more
interesting it's not just about fitting
video clips on a timeline it's about
providing a a navigable collection of
videos that enable two people to extract
their own stories in some way tell me
one or two of the challenges of making
it out like this one yeah one so the
main outstanding challenges is about
what to do with all this video so at the
moment on people are just recording
videos it's not streamed it's not
broadcast that just recording videos
this says that sit on their phones and
ideally we'd want to get those videos
online as fast as possible to provide
some some kind of reasonable online
experience
now what happens when we have 10,000
people or spectating the marathon
they're only going to be in a few mobile
phone cells and there's going to be many
more than usual so none of them are
going to have a reasonable mobile phone
signal and so if we start trying to
upload lots and lots of videos from
people's mobile phones this that the
network is just not gonna not going to
handle it and so what one approach we
might take to this is to think about
again is that another factor that we can
use to kind of organize people
orchestrate people so if you and I are
stood in the same spot maybe we can say
we'll only upload your video because
yours is better for some reason rather
than trying to upload them both because
that has an effect on the network if we
have a collection of people and we kind
of want to instruct them in some way we
do so a number of levels so one might be
two is to get people to collect
different shots for example for our
video corpus the other might be with an
understanding of actually the network is
pretty flaky here so only one of us
should be recording so either we get us
both to record and only pick what we
continue to be the best or most
appropriate shot whatever that is or we
might say well no you save your battery
life for something else you wouldn't be
able to upload anything you record it
anyway so i'll record stuff and upload
it so there's a bunch of levels we can
think about this one is about coverage
and like raw coverage somebody being in
a spot filming something one is the
finer details of exactly what the
multiple shots are and one is other kind
of i guess more infrastructural
considerations like who's got the most
battery life who will be able to upload
stuff even if they can record it what's
the best use of the network that these
people are operating with who's got
credit yes who's got credit
you